salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
alors aujourd'hui on est de retour dans
la carrer abandonnée c'est ça c'est
vraiment un des meilleurs spots qu'on a
fait on a trouvé des centaines de
munitions des armes de la dynamique et
surtout la dynamite était dans des sacs
poubelles et là on est tombé sur quoi un
sac poubelle mort on va dire on va
commencer là par contre simplement on va
faire un petit pont
oh [__] ça y est
je me suis pris de l'eau
ça commence bien
ici il y a pas mal de déchets donc en
même temps on va nettoyer on a déjà un
saut qui est rempli plastique
reprendre nos aimants et allons-y ouais
c'est parti l'eau est assez basse vu
qu'on est en fin d'été il y a pas eu
encore les pluies on n'a jamais vu l'eau
aussi basse et ici on est sur un endroit
qui était inaccessible la dernière fois
qu'on a pêché ici donc on avait jeté un
petit peu les mains de de là-haut
d'ailleurs là où il y a rasta et Sydney
qui nous regarde mais c'est vrai que on
devrait pouvoir lancer un petit peu plus
loin voilà faut être vigilant parce
qu'il y a pas mal de voitures aussi dans
cette carrière surtout au milieu et
là-bas donc on va essayer de pas non
plus s'accrocher magnet away
commence par un lancer très moyen mais
c'est dû au nœud de la corde on va
peut-être quelque chose quand même au
poids de les morts je sais pas
encore alors une cuillère de pêche
surtout et après c'est de la vieille
c'est incroyable et un bout de moulinet
de pêche aussi
on en avait pas là
déjà qui doivent se poser dans le coin
mais bon proto ici il faut le faire
quand même alors j'ai attaque quelque
chose oui oui
peut-être des bois appris des bois pris
dans les algues attaque quelque chose
quand même
ah c'est une lance une lance de saut
d'époque ça pourrait remplacer le saut
là-bas
il reste un morceau du saut
e
c'était peut-être des munitions
bien joué avec la cuillère de pêche on
commence à avoir du matériel ici c'était
rempli de munition à chaque fois ce qui
fait la première munition il paye
l'apéro
allez la première munition paye l'apéro
on a dit
la première émission
mais ça c'est des munitions
c'est un peu effacé quand même
elle est sympa dites nous en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez première
trouvaille sympa bien joué c'est bon
deuxième j'ai eu chaud pour l'apéro
je crois qu'on est exactement sur la
même
hop ouais c'est les mêmes et ça super
ancien ça doit venir d'un outil c'est
pas ce que Romain il a trouvé dans son
terrain presque ça ressemble
quelque chose aussi là
gastrique classique
bon bah c'est sympa ça commence bien moi
j'aime bien pour un spot déjà fait c'est
cool
allez on continue jade quelque chose
vous en pensez quoi les chiens
j'ai peut-être un truc là-bas je remonte
vite pour pas que ça frotte trop dans
les rochers
ouais ouais
des clés un trousseau de clés
et ici aussi
d'un coup donc effectivement les
munitions c'est la
munitions
c'est peut-être un piège à poisson
un enfant
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quelque chose
de pêche à l'aimant
il y a eu un drame dans le coin
encore un leurre de pêche
ok quand elle vient de remonter il y a
un sac plastique enfin quelque chose
dans du plastique
la droite tu as un vrai sac plastique
alors en ce qui concerne les aimants on
utilise avec Quentin les barbarianes de
chez Maison de la détection donc c'est
cela et regardez ça il y a pas mieux
comme sponso voilà le Barbarian ce qu'il
arrive à trouver en étant tiré juste là
donc trois munitions ça c'est 1600 kg de
force et on a Jade qui est avec nous
aujourd'hui et Jade elle utilise les
manières qui est pas mal aussi qui fait
le taf puisque dans les algues il arrive
à remonter ça le terror c'est 1200 kg et
c'est celui qu'on conseille en général
pour débuter il fait tard
il est validé aussi vous avez le code
promo pêcheur de trésor qui s'affiche
ici l'offre au moins 5% sur toute la
boutique y compris sur les détecteurs de
métaux
ça c'est les c'est des des obus c'est
des obus entier et rien vide
heureusement
et en fait ils avaient des têtes en
aluminium qui se vissent parce que là
donc il est pas si vide que ça il est
facile il est creux là mais il y a la
tête qui est encore là donc il y a
peut-être une petite charge dans la tête
aussi quand même puisque c'est la
détonation qui se fait là et puis vous
avez la poudre ici donc attention mais
bon ça reste ça reste du tout petit obus
des pollution quand même c'est bien de
les sortir allez on va chercher d'autres
ok encore une et tu vois elles étaient
sur un clip
tire des munitions comme ça une de plus
juste ici donc sûrement une caisse en de
munition qui est en train de se
décomposer et non
ah oui une cuillère de pêche encore
là-bas
[Musique]
ça va peut-être donner des indices
ça pourrait être la caisse mais c'est
vrai que les munitions ils n'avaient
quand même plus la première fois il y
avait des fois où on lançait on remonte
les mains avec une vingtaine dessus
c'était des vrais hérissons de munitions
qui ne sont pas aimantées c'est ça le
truc là je viens de faire une lame de
couteau cassée
la première remontée du cousin en direct
allez on l'a vu sauter pas grand chose
mais il y a peut-être des munitions on
sait jamais
moi aussi
il y a une seule
de bien jouer
exo on fait la belle alors on est encore
sur la revanche et Quentin a envoyé du
lourd puisqu'il a fait deux munitions
classiques les mêmes donc 45 à CP on en
avait fait de par ici très peu
1911 et des Thompson et des Thompson
pour Seconde Guerre mondiale sûrement on
regardera le culot mais ça c'est cool le
grappin tu fais des choses différentes
elle a encore utilisable en plus
Quentin pour la trappe de ta salle de
bain
ah ouais effectivement
pas longtemps ah oui
ça ressemble à une caisse de munition en
vrai
en tout cas c'est très ancien
c'était troué d'origine les pros nous
dirons peut-être oh j'ai quelque chose
petite bobine de cuivre
deux choses
comme ça c'est étonnant c'est super
solide normalement
[Rires]
c'est hyper solide
ça va te porter chance
avec des munitions ou quoi on en a déjà
fait
il y a quelque chose dans ton sac
il faut faire l'ouverture en vidéo
non quoi
ça pue ça pue
vas-y joue
énormément il y a des choses
c'est bizarre c'est des papiers ah mais
je crois que c'était de la dynamique
c'est les cartons comme les bâtons de
dynamite bah du coup on va vous mettre
des images déjà trouvé des bâtons de
dynamite en meilleure état ici mais
c'est clairement les mêmes
trouvaille Jade
oh une corde un an c'est pas du filet de
t'as pas vu derrière bravo
et
tu as fait quelques trucs sympas
ouh là oui
oh ça va les différentes non elle est en
bas c'est la même elle est cru elle est
creuse on dirait que la poudre c'est
échappé dedans si ça fait ça non bah oui
il a l'air bien massif
tu veux le ramener pour faire barbecue
oh
il reste vachement de choses en dessous
de l'arbre il y a un leurre de pêche
grenouille il y a du calibre 12 il y a
une munition et à la caisse des
munitions c'est sûr maintenant que c'est
ça
il y a des trucs
c'est pas du tout c'est plus petit
mais bon ça reste pour la chasse
sympa franchement il est très stylé ce
l'heure de pêche grenouille
des gorgeur d'accord il est mort
il y a un liquide dedans
je suis arrivé
tu veux boire moi je pense que tu
devrais boire tu as trouvé
ah c'est bizarre mais j'aime bien la
petite nous en commentaire si vous savez
ce que c'est garde le fermer pour
l'instant je pense en demandant aux
abonnés d'abord et selon ce que c'est on
l'ouvre on l'ouvre pas comme ça on fait
pas de bêtises vous m'éviter
en tout cas
très sympa
franchement il y a moyen de faire des
trucs parce que empêcher tout le temps
de là-bas et on a ramené plein de trucs
pas trop aimanté mais bon après c'est
vrai qu'il y a les il y a les algues
aussi
un sac un sac un sac
vas-y je te laisse l'ouvrir
le cousin qui a trouvé un objet dans un
sac grâce au grappin
ça peut être tout et n'importe quoi
c'est quelque chose de Lester
ce qui reste pas des os des choses comme
ça
dommage
le sac ici ouvert ah si sinon ça c'est
quoi ça
c'est des os si c'est des os ça
regarde
c'est clairement des petits os
ça c'est un crâne ça
les animaux qui ont été envoyés
là-dedans
bon pas fou comme
le produit grappin là-bas
[Applaudissements]
il y a un autre sac dans le sac c'est
bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est plein plein
elles sont pas aimantées
[Musique]
regardez tout ce qu'il y a
de toute façon on a vu un sac un sac
dans un sac c'est très bon signe à
chaque fois
tu vois clairement que c'est du plomb
non non
super
OK
ça commence à devenir short ici
dans la bouche on dirait c'est le plus
clair
on va essayer de l'attraper et de
l'enlever mais ça a l'air très dur
d'attraper un canard surtout que ça a
l'air d'être le plus craintif comme par
hasard est une professionnelle
en plus
[Musique]
c'est un échec
loin je crois que bon ben tant pis
je pense que c'est une mission qui a
échoué
ouais
elle est bonne
de spot on est en face de la falaise et
oui j'attends quelque chose déjà
qu'est-ce donc
il y a des choses c'est déjà bon signe
ok romain un truc lourd
je vais pas tirer en dessous de la
falaise
[__] ça soulève pardon pour le gros
mot
je me suis chier
oui tu as raison c'est quand même
dangereux mais ah oui c'est
lacrymotement
regardez ce qui vient de trouver notre
cousin donc oui ça peut être dangereux
ben je pense que c'est une grenade à gaz
c'est de lacrymo ça va pas le trouver
avec
la référence là on vous affichera ce que
c'est
sympa
c'est pas grave c'est le principal
un bout de pot d'échappement peut-être
ouais je pense
ah non c'est fermé il y a un bouchon
c'est un bouchon non ça se dévisse
si elle va loin dedans
je suis un véhicule un peu bizarre tu
sais regarde le bouchon il fait un peu
trappe à essence
en commentaire à quel véhicule ça peut
appartenir si c'est ça d'ailleurs mais
le bouchon fait penser
une 45 ACP comme j'ai fait donc ça ouais
c'est ça balle de munitions de Colt 1911
première seconde guerre mondiale et
regarde le 42 là que tu vois ça veut
dire 1942 ok donc ça va belle trouva
ouais ouais morceau de scooter ça je
pense
c'est un indice
avec la durite
voilà ça c'est une pièce de scooter
c'est sûr
si vous pouvez nous dire ce que c'est en
commentaire
waouh une suspension
ouais c'est vieux ça
[Musique]
c'est une très vieille suspension aussi
ça c'est sympa
[Musique]
enfin
si je le perds pas dans les rochers
du cambrioleur il est incroyable bon
état en plus comme quoi il peut rester
des armes c'est une arme de meurtre déjà
ça va choper ça c'est qu'il peut rester
du lourd le machin il est massif
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce travail
alors c'est quoi la différence entre les
deux
à la forme ouais mais pourquoi cette
forme
tu as pas d'ogive ok d'accord
ça ça rigole pas et des munitions de
FAMAS récentes
années 90 c'est
quelle année celui-là 88 elles sont bien
conservées
ça monte ça vient ça vient
enfin
on dirait qu'on a pas tout mais une
mobylette peut-être du coup un cadre de
moto tu vois vaut mieux de passer un
roman qui remonte de là-bas
d'accord
sans doute
voyez ça fait un moment qu'il est là il
y a encore le feu arrière les
clignotants
c'est quoi
c'est le réservoir
et oui pour ça l'essence ça explique
tout tu vois toutes les séances on a
réussi à en sauver quand même
ouais c'est pour ça il reste d'où les
tâches
bien joué merci
Claire de pêche franchement il est
correct
ah ouais c'est un terror on dirait
là tu te mets bien
alors attends
faudrait essayer de faire une boucle
pour attraper autour ce qui est étonnant
c'est que d'habitude quand on perdant
c'est l'autre côté qui accroché je sais
pas comment il s'est dérouillé ah mais
il faut qu'on garde les deux bouts de la
corde
ça va pas ça va serrer ça tu crois oui
pour Noël déjà
oh oui c'est bon alors attends
maintenant alors stop attends là
c'est qui les pros là c'est pas fini
c'est pas fini les gars
[Musique]
mais comment ils ont attrapé quelque
chose il doit y avoir un autre aimant ou
un grappin de l'autre côté une corde il
doit y avoir un grappin moi je parie sur
un grappin
de l'autre côté
ce serait marrant ce qui est de voir ce
qui est au bout
j'ai pas mes gants
il y a un truc à lâché
je pense que c'était que la corde
ils ont travaillé
je pense qu'elle est doublée vraiment
c'est un aimant de magnéta
ctions il y a quoi entre le terror et le
zizi
en plus
si vous reconnaissez votre aimant
envoyer envoyez-nous un petit message
privé on va trouver on va trouver un
arrangement et si vous voulez faire
semblant que c'est le vôtre on voyait
quand même un message privé
ok en commentaire ça c'est un aimant
hardcore donc vous les trouvez sur le
site de maison de la détection je pense
pas que ce soit le Easy donc c'est déjà
pas mal
déjà regarde attends pas mal pour
débuter en soi surtout que ils auraient
perdu un Barbot si ils avaient testé au
barbare ici
allez on vous tiendra au courant des
découvertes de Romain
j'essaye tout de suite
c'est un aimant maudit non
alors
c'est la fin de cette vidéo de pêche à
l'aimant pour nous on est revenu sur ce
spot on vous a dit qu'il restait
sûrement des choses et ben c'est vrai il
en restait ouais franchement c'est
éclaté une journée très sportive
n'hésitez pas à nous dire en commentaire
si vous êtes déjà venu ici sans dire
l'endroit comme ça on ramène pas encore
plus de monde n'hésitez pas à nous dire
si vous êtes déjà venu nous on viendra
en tout cas ouais nous on viendra
peut-être qu'on peut se faire une
session ici tous les ans ça peut être
sympa de voir si ce lieu va être enfin
propre un jour en tout cas une quantité
folle de plastique on a un sachet
pouvait le rempli et de munitions aussi
ouais toujours comme d'hab on déposera
tout ça en gendarmerie et on vous dit à
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à l'aimant